[موسيقى]
والله الحمد لله نحن اهل عز واهل كرم اهل
ضيعه بس الله قدر علينا وكتب علينا هيك
ولايك دورنا كلنا تهدمت وهي اكبر برهان
قدامك وهذه هالنساء وهالاطفال هيدا كلها
مبارح نامت بالشوارع الزلم الزلم بالشوارع
النسوان والاولاد نيمناها تحت الشجر تحت
سوينا لهم
وحاله يرسل لهم ونحن طلبنا بدنا تكبيره
عدد يعني لهالخيم بس خيم بس خيم بدنا يا
اخي ما بدنا شيء بدنا خينا بس يسعفونا
بخيم القاويها للاطفال وهالنساء هالاطفال
قويه ونحن بندبر حالنا يا اخي ما في حل
انه ترجع البيوت
ما خرج
برهان قدامك
كله كله ما ظل ولا بيت سال اللي هبط هبط
واللي ما هبط كلهم صدع ما حدا دور ثلاث
طوابق كله على الارض
اسمه قريه بديه
30 شهيد طلع منه الله اكبر
اليوم كم عدد القريه يعني ما يعادل 260
الى 275 عيله عيله
عنا مراكز ايواء
دورنا عفوا اراضينا كلها بنصبه ايواء
الاطفال وهالنساء